um hey rich you're like that i never had
by the way speaking of t what are your
thoughts on overcoming addictions
spec porn addictions and overcoming that
i don't know what spec
is porn addictions and overcoming that i
don't know a little off topic
by the way i'm from tdot i'll put it to
you this way because i had a guy bring
this up the other day
in my community about no fap there isn't
a single guy out there
with sexual options that even considers
no fap or
you know having addictions to things
like that if you've got
access to intimacy and that can be with
one woman can be with multiple women
it's entirely up to you
this isn't a problem this is a problem
for guys because they're not getting out
there and interacting with people in the
real world and dating women they're too
busy you know hammering them out
so you know it's up to you on what you
want to take
as far as your priorities
you